um how stupid you sound as a parent i
mean you as a parent imagine this
you're sending your child to university
wanting the best for them
as muslims right and then you send them
into a super
hyper sexualized charged environment
where the youth are at their
peak in terms of testosterone and
estrogen production that means they are
at their sexual peak
as to whether or not they practice that
it's a different question but they are
sexually charged
individuals at their prime age at
university age
you send them into this environment and
you tell him be patient
you tell her be patient and all they're
seeing out there
is the meat market and everything's
haram until they get married there ain't
no halal meat out there
it's it's just a mess and then you
you abdullah you're the parent you get
to go in the next room
at the end of the day and sleep with
your wife or you get to sleep with your
husband while telling your kid to be
[Music]
patient
[Music]
salafi salafi is a is a methodology of
islam
it's a methodology of islam where the
salaf were
the companions of the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him
and so when the and the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him he says you know the
people who are upon guidance
are those who follow me and myself you
know the right the goddess
and so we say we are salafi we follow
them
you know we follow the the prophet
muhammad according to the understanding
of the salaf
because it was the salaf who gave us and
translated and transmitted to us the
religion as we know it
so we say we're salafi because we follow
that it's an orthodox form of islam you
know
that follows uh yeah i just explained it
basically i'm just repeating myself ten
times
yeah so when i say i'm selling muslim a
lot of people you know and there's a lot
of anger and hatred against salafi
muslims because they're quite orthodox
and you know
uh everything is you know allah the
saying of allah and the saying of his
messenger
you know and this is why a lot of people
hate me also because they come at me
with stuff that i say and i do
but at no point am i saying or doing
anything that i can't back
with a saying of allah's messenger i
might be eccentric attic i admit it you
know i'll be very controversial and i'll
say things to trigger people
but at the end of the day if someone
comes with me you know on a private chat
or publicly i can whack them over the
head with the quran and the sunnah
i used to be an imam don't don't mess
with me i really know my stuff more than
people think they
they think i'm just you know some
regular old ghetto dude or something and
i was at a man for years
i get a lot of study under my belt i i
lived in mecca and medina
i studied with the ulama i sat with them
you know not in a big way but
i sat in the roost in the circles with
some of them you know i got you know i
got my lessons so you know don't
yeah don't don't play with me
[Music]
dude that's why i was gonna ask you man
i i hope you uh your number one fan is
tuning in bro
yeah you got to get a lot of hate for
this one so
she you know what i'm talking about
right your number one fan
which one the the the one from canada
the [ __ ]
she's on the bench right now but we
don't know if she could be hitting the
slot
this is a psychopath man that's like a
weirdo i don't know what's with so many
people bro they
these people can't be making money they
must be broke man i spend all my time
either doing interviews or
you know making money online i don't
know how they got time to be on the line
doing crazy stuff i really don't this
is what they do wrong
you're basically living in this
post-modern world and there's dunya
but you try not to do anybody you're
literally following the quran in the
sunnah
and people still got a problem with that
when being a selfie
uh was exactly the type of man you had
to be to proliferate the ummah
and to start from one man salah sallam
to
almost 2 billion but that's what i'm
saying you know if you want to live the
way
that you want to and you keep it in line
with the book on the sunnah people are
going to hate you man they're gonna hate
you
just because you're happy people don't
like to see you happy
that whole story of everybody loves the
underdog and all this stuff and see to
come up
it's not true it's not true they they're
angry and if you go out and you do what
you want to do
and you do it especially in a
permissible way people are going to be
upset with you
and it's not going to make sense so
don't try and make sense of it
don't try stick to the book stick to the
sun and do what's right
you know by you and yours you know well
first and foremost by allah you know by
law under the command of the messenger
and man don't worry about nothing else
and that's going to be tough for young
guys because
you know your social circle is out there
all you got is your family and your
social circle
outside out in school or whatever else
if they're mad at you
it's tough it's a tough life you've got
to be an exceptional person to be able
to stand up to that type of pressure
you know i got a question i got a
question for you that i'm sure a lot of
the viewers have
all right so what advice would you give
to young men out there
who are not a hundred percent
established
all right let's say let's say you know
let's say they got a little something
you know they're working on it or
they're in school or something like that
and bro they obviously want a wife
they obviously want to start a family or
or you know they obviously want to do
something else if you know what i mean
but it's like how would they go about
doing that
should they even go about uh getting
into
a marriage having in the car with a
woman at that point in time or should
they actually
wait it out and um you know kind of go
in a little bit more in terms of
financial means in terms of uh their
success to where they are
just a little bit more grounded before
uh getting a woman and being able to
support her
and craig before you take the floor like
i had a question too i was gonna wait
for you to answer but i had the exact
same
question i was just gonna say you talk
about value a lot and although it's
subjective
to you as a man what are the five most
things that men should do
for value and it kind of you know leans
into this question
and then maybe you could talk about
women too if you have any advice for
them
okay oh that was a lot
start with the one that i said bro yeah
okay
um younger guys man um i'm of the
opinion
that uh if you come from a muslim family
if you're a revert then it's going to be
a little bit tough
but if you come from a traditionally
muslim family i call it you know
culturally islamic family where you know
generations upon generations pakistan
india you know saudi arabia wherever
where the people were you know born and
raised muslim as far as they can
remember
then you should involve your parents as
best your ability and they're going to
resist you obviously
it's obvious if you're in university or
if you're in school or something it's
going to be very difficult to get to get
married it is her
it is a woman's right that you care for
her financially
um so you know if you get married you
should be capable of doing that
but at the same time you know if you're
in university because the standards have
changed somehow
you know where a guy is supposed to have
all this goofy stuff you know
um in order to get married that um
there's going to be a sister out there
that's going to be in a similar position
who wants to get married and you know
and so
i think you it's incumbent upon the
youth today to speak to their parents
and it's very important for parents to
understand
the position that they're putting their
children in that they should aid and
assist them in getting married to the
best of their ability
if your son or daughter is staying in
your house help them get married and let
them stay in your house as a married
couple
i mean that's is it uncomfortable
probably
but is it better than your child going
out there committing zinna and
fornicating you know
absolutely you know and don't tell your
kids oh wait
get a job finish university if you're a
parent
you know um i'm just going to be honest
i want to slap every parent right here
say
that i really just wanna i just wanna go
up and punch him in the nose
so you bleed before and just so i can
just stand over you
and just make sure you hear every word
coming out of my mouth just make you a
helpless victim so you can listen
and understand how i'm getting angry so
you have to forgive me
um how stupid you sound as a parent i
mean you as a parent imagine this
you're sending your child to university
wanting the best for them
as muslims right and then you send them
into a super hyper sexualized charged
environment
where the youth are at their peak in
terms of testosterone and estrogen
production that means they are at their
sexual peak
as to whether or not they practice that
it's a different question but they are
sexually charged individuals at their
prime
age at university age you send them into
this environment
and you tell him be patient you tell her
be patient
and all they're seeing out there is the
meat market and everything's haram until
they get married
there ain't no halal meat out there it's
it's just a mess
and then you you abdullah you're
the parent you get to go in the next
room at the end of the day
and sleep with your wife or you get to
sleep with your husband while telling
your kid to be patient
while they're walking around looking at
the hottest people that they can see
in their particular environment and zone
imagine that
so you as the father you tell your son
be patient son
then you go to work as the father you
see attractive women
you know and then you come home and you
get to release your your attention
that you've built up over the day with
your wife
and then you send your son into our
environment and you tell him for four
years to be patient
are you are you kidding me are you
kidding me
i should well i yeah slap a man for
saying something like that
what are you talking about help your son
help your daughter
protect them because all you're doing is
sending me into the into a freaking meat
grinder
you know it's just bad it's bad and we
know the stories that there are a lot of
muslims falling into sin out there
nowadays we know it it's not a secret
you know i deal with it personally the
messages i get
it would i tell a lot of people it would
break you if you heard some of the
stories these brothers and sisters are
telling me
of their life stories and what they're
going through in terms of trying to like
just keep it hello and ended up falling
into something haram
and my parents told me to be patient
yeah well how did that work out
so what do i think i think parents
should help their kids get married
and do whatever it takes to make sure it
works
you as a parent go talk to those parents
make an agreement between yourselves
understanding the environment that your
children are going to be in that it is a
difficult environment how difficult is
it if
a son and a daughter you know from
different families are together in
university
you know and he crosses his wife's path
left and right and all the time sure
there's going to be temptation whatever
else but they know at the end of the day
they can go home and make their private
parts connect
and release that somewhere in a
permissible way
it makes it easier so for me this is
what i think and if you don't have that
option then you're just going to have to
be an exceptional individual as a man
and you're going to have to go to school
and then you're going to have to work
you know and you're going to have to
it's not going to be easy and you know
it's going to feel impossible
but it's not you know and so that's
that's another option
you know you just got to stand out it'll
it's four years
you can do it as a young person you can
go to school full-time and you can work
part-time
you know is it is it easy no i'm not
gonna act like it is
you know but uh how serious you were
about this and how serious you were
about your islam
do what it takes you know thanks
uh if i had yeah i'm you so uh let me
speak real quick before you go um
i gotta head out here because me and my
family were about to go somewhere
brother it's been it's been a pleasure
man i'm sorry i have to go like i have
so many more questions but
i'm sure it's not the last time we're
all going to talk hopefully now
they're going to continue for sure for
sure so i'll definitely tune into the
video to watch
what i missed but y'all take care of
yourselves all right
yo have a good rest of your life the
year man on your break
and uh we'll have you back volleyball
you take care
i can't hear you but you froze i was
like yo we're gonna do a
we're gonna run a live stream with him
one day insha'allah so you're gonna be
here
peace love y'all
yeah you know what's funny though he was
he was on our live stream and he told us
that his mic wasn't working
or something like that like his audio
wasn't working and then he messaged me
last night he's like
yo i figured out what it was and i was
like what was it and he never got back
yeah i doubt it's zoom man you have to
excuse me i get heated on this topic i
get upset so if i went a little bit like
right there yeah excuse me man oh man
you're good man it's it's these these
are good things to get heated on
yeah yeah
you ask me about five five factors five
things that uh a man should work on
what what are the five most i guess
highest yield things
to make a man higher value and then for
women too
because you have daughters you're around
women you want the best for women too so
well i mean in terms of like attraction
in terms of women it's pretty easy
i mean women got it on cruise control
you know you know as they say
women are born men are made you know the
burden of performance has always been
upon men i mean we have to prove
ourselves in general
um so you know that we're worthy you
know when women look for particular
things and men men just look for
attractive
you know beautiful women who are
generally young i mean so that's really
so for women my advice i have a video
out on it basically is like do your best
to secure a high value man as early as
possible
you know um the younger the better you
know uh we're not talking we're not
talking crazy here when i talk younger
but i'm just saying you know it's like
when from legal age
legal marital age you should really
start looking men
are not attracted this is to the ladies
men are not attracted to your degrees
we don't give a dang about that we don't
care about that stuff no guy cares oh my
gosh
look at that that phd she has wow
i just really want to have kids with her
nobody nobody guys aren't out there
doing that we're not interested in that
you know
you know if anything it's like oh she
got a phd man she's going to want me to
do dishes and take out the trash you
know
50 50 dudes are more like that you know
like
you know it's more like the opposite
the concept that you know the higher
educated you are is the more problematic
you are
so it's like nobody of course we're not
saying you know don't learn to read and
write you know because people like on
the internet like to go into extremes
america said women you know be barefoot
not educated not reading no that's not
what i'm saying
what i'm saying is like it just doesn't
help your case with high value men
you know uh having you know uh
an education yeah and women are gonna
argue with me on this they'll be like no
that's not true
but let me tell you something it's 100
true you know
whether you want to accept it or not is
a different thing high value men
are not interested you know in women
with high degree
levels and all that type of stuff
they're just generally not
interested in it yes are there are men
who are but they're not so for a woman
if you've got it on easy mode the
younger you are the more attractive you
are you know there are women who get
older and more attractive but in general
those women were super attractive when
they were young so
secure yourself a high value man you
know who's going to care for you take
care you know love you and everything
and you know
not just you know uh jump your bones and
then divorce you
find that guy you don't marry him for
guys you got to become that high value
guy
you know that women want and they throw
themselves that you know
and for you that means you know
competence in all things
we starting with islam you know
competence in what you do what you know
what you speak about what you work your
work all this stuff competent leads to
you being what
confident you know because when you're
competent you know
in life in general you become confident
you become comfortable
you know and it's natural and this is
like you know this is the difference
between making and faking and actually
being real you want to be
an actually naturally confident guy and
that only comes
from competence and competence comes
from experience
you want to be all of these things
experience you want to be fit
and you want to have a good social sense
you want to have social acumen
you know um and this includes your
fashion sense maybe you could maybe
make even fashion a separate category
but you know we'll just
call social acumen also having a you
know a decent sense of fashion
and this doesn't mean you got to go out
and wear louis vuitton and all that
stuff
if you wear your thobe and whatever else
you know what color though works for you
what if you're gonna wear it a good
truck know what what what you know if
you're gonna wear a
turban or a butcher what looks good on
you you know just
know that you look good because when you
look good you feel good
when you feel good you naturally are
more comfortable as a person and you're
more
again competent not competent but
confident that's just attractive to
women in general
so you know i have those things on walk
you know you know
just your fitness your experience
competent confidence you know
um social acumen and yeah you get your
money right
obviously any man
good stuff the attraction markers for
women are different than men
and women have higher levels of
attraction markers than men
they look for a lot of things in men and
men look for very few things in women
and i i mentioned this uh in my vetting
guide it's not a sales pitch but i'm
just saying
women they start off from a position of
disqualifying men
they disqualify men because women have a
natural sense of
uh uh non-scarcity when it comes to men
she understands that if she disqualifies
you and walks away there's going to be
10 guys there waiting to you know take
your place tomorrow
so they start from a position of
disqualification oh look at the way he
dresses up
oh look at the way he talked listen the
way he talks ugh this guy he's like
he seems shy or just that the other he
seems whatever all these things are not
attractive don't think that women like
the shy guy
you know some do but that's the
exception it's not the norm most women
like confident guys that doesn't mean
you're an
arrogant jerk but confident
so women will disqualify you on a lot of
things
men on the opposite flip side they look
for qualifiers
and men are always trying to qualify
women hey i met this girl and she's
amazing this that the other and blah
blah blah you you've heard this before
right
and the guy's talking about this amazing
girl and then you come across and you
meet her it's like hey this is my god i
told you about her this at the other
you're like man she's real average man
what you talking about you know i'm just
like
dude i thought this girl was amazing and
we're not even talking looks here just
everything you talked about you just
like i thought you said she was funny
yeah like man she jokes as dry as like
you know
pizza without any sauce it's like what's
going on here you know
and that's because he's qualifying a
woman because he's just happy to have a
woman around him
so men operate from a position of
qualifying women they look for things to
qualify a woman to make her like you
know
make her all attractive and like why he
likes her and women will do the opposite
you know so that's been a lot man
i don't wanna i don't wanna say when but
what was i doing more recently
i mean he's not wrong not at all we as
men we we do tend to qualify it's like
we go around saying yo look we found
this guy just like abu said we found a
guy oh
my god we found a girl who's like she's
there she's that like she's she's doing
this with her life she's this type of
way to
to something that would work with me and
it's like women don't do that man
they're always out here like oh i met
this guy but he's this or but if only he
was this
he's not tall enough he's not tall
enough exactly it's like it's like
it's like i met this guy he's perfect
but it's just like uh
he's he's he's five foot four you know
uh
he's just he's he's a plumber
yep yeah so it's like i don't know um
you made one point on
on competence i wanna i wanna set
something in here because there's
different types of competence right
there's
conscious competence and there's
unconscious competence right so you can
consciously be aware that you're trying
your hardest and working to be competent
and this is the beginning stage when it
becomes hard because if there's a moment
of incompetence
you feel discouraged this is all things
in life but
those moments of incompetence eventually
become
conscious competence or sorry
unconscious competence where you're just
unconsciously
being competent and if competence equals
confidence then you're also
unconsciously being confident
and i feel like listen yo just one more
time bro you lost me
i lost you mm-hmm okay so
if competence equals confidence
then being unconsciously competent
means you're also being unconsciously
confident
so if people recognize that eventually
they'll get to a place
when they're unconsciously competent
where they're just naturally
naturally being competent then they'll
naturally be everything else that
follows that competence
which is confidence and the other
amazing attributes that come from that i
just wanted to add that in there because
me myself
i'm in that stage of trying to be as
competent as possible
and when a man like me slips up it
becomes discouraging
i think that's normal but then i think
also this comes back to what i was
talking about experience
and um with experience it comes to
understanding that not everything's ever
always going to go the way you wanted to
you know i mean it's just it's
impossible
you know like my wife she watched me
build my first crypto miner
and dude
zero experience i just knew what i had
to order i looked up the parts i ordered
the parts
and then i just i just started watching
youtube videos and she
saw my frustration dude it was literally
i'm not even joking it was every single
step
i ran into major problems to the point
that when i was on discord talking to
dudes they were like yo
how are you even having these problems
and then one guy said
he says you know what you did he said
you decided you wanted to learn how to
fly an airplane but not only did you
decide you wanted to
learn how to fly an airplane from
youtube you decided to build your own
airplane at the same time
he's like this is what you did but you
know because i understood
that not everything's going to go your
way it wasn't really such a destructive
blow to me every single time i hit an
obstacle
i'd sit down sometimes and i'd i just
walk away from it for two days you know
and i'd just be like you know what cuz
i'd be so mad
and i'd be like you know what and she's
just like you know okay this guy he's
just chilling whatever else but it was
never like
it was never excuse me it was never a
blow to my confidence you know
internally
you know to the point there was like you
know it made her question me as to
whether or not you know if there was a
serious case situation
that you know it would affect her
because then she saw that you know okay
this guy's chilling with her else
and i'd come back and i'd i'd make it
work well why what was i doing for the
next two days i was i was watching
youtube videos i was
sitting back and reading i was relaxing
my mind by actually learning about what
i'm doing
you know or what i'm doing wrong so
there comes a point with the experience
where you start to experience failure
and that's not a bad thing
you know because you can't know success
without failure and if you do
the moment you do hit failure it's gonna
hit you hard
you know but after a while a failure
after failure after failure you know
practicing and then improving and then
actually reaching your goal and becoming
successful now i got my minor in there
it just runs i don't even look at it i
drive off on vacation
i was gone meeting my new wife for like
a week that thing was running i didn't
have to touch it
it just runs and it makes me money you
know but the point is
it's like once you reach that success
then it like it
triple increases your confidence do you
know what i mean
but along those lines it wasn't
crippling to fail
and understand that i was i was reaching
nearly 5 000
euros in building that thing the desire
to succeed was extreme
do you know what i mean nearly i got
away but like four and a half you know
and all this type of stuff but it's just
it's
really significant you know the the
pressure you know so
with trial and error experience comes
that confidence and comes that
competence you know
so it's just a matter of practice just
keep failing and it's not that's not the
goal
but the goal is just basically fail and
succeed you know
so disappointment doesn't become a thing
for you you know just like yeah it's
it's just part of it's part of the
mission it's part of the the trip
you know yeah yeah i think that's very
profound because a lot of people
you know forget that along the way
subhanallah so you mentioned you took a
break right
how important or necessary would you say
taking a break
is when you reach that kind of stage
it's very important man
sometimes sometimes you get so involved
and immersed in something
that all you see is the problem so you
have to walk away
i gave an example it's like it was from
relationships but then i realized it's
in all things
some people get so immersed in their
problems it's like facing a wall
and they're right here nose to the wall
and that's all they see
the problem if they were only to walk
left or right they would find the window
or the door but they're so close to the
problem and they're so immersed in the
problem that all they see is that
problem
sometimes you got to stop just walk away
from it and then turn around and look at
it and you're like oh
dude there's a freaking door right there
what am i doing
you know i mean sometimes you have to
walk away from this stuff and this is
very important for you as a man
you know because um you know women look
for this in you they look for you know
they look for a guy who is a leader
the the vast majority of women you know
want a guy who can lead
and if you only see problems and you
never find solutions we have to be
solution oriented as men
that's how we built entire societies and
nations and you know
great structures and all the stuff
that's going on whether anybody likes to
hear it or not
men are the builders and maintainers of
society in the modern world
and that's because we are solution
oriented we are explorers
and we are solution oriented people so
you have to be like that you can't be
problem oriented
you know you have to be solution
oriented
just
you got anything else on your mind
romney um
nothing currently nothing currently
inshallah fast question i'll if we can
i just want to tell you right now like
before we even like talked for the first
time before we chopped it up me you and
anha
before the podcast way before the
podcast i just wanna let you know man
the work you're doing for the
the muslim community and just men in
general is profound man
exactly on behalf of the nominees
may allah reward you and increase you
for that i mean
i face a lot of opposition for some
reason i don't know why it's just been
it's always been my intention to help
guys get married and stay married i
don't even want anybody to go through
anything i went through
people get on me about it you know i've
been married a lot of times more times
than i ever
thought that i would be i never never
once did i think to myself i'm gonna be
married and divorced so many times
you know um and so i don't want anybody
to go through that because i haven't
married a woman
and let me think hold on before i make
this statement
i'd say 90 of the cases the women i was
married to i love them
i truly loved them you know and so it
was never an intention for me to like
you know
be separated from them when i got
married i was like this is this girl i'm
gonna make this work
you know but uh for whatever reasons my
own purposes and you know my own
shortcomings or their shortcomings
you know um i looked at all of them and
uh you know i compiled that into my
current day work as abu american
um those shortcomings on both sides i
put together and i said you know what
this is just stuff that's completely
avoidable you know
and uh and so i try and help people
avoid those mistakes
because they're widespread and they're
common when i started looking at my
problems and talking to other men
and going online and reading the lives
of other men i was like we're all doing
the same stupid mistakes like you said
social programming
this is social programming on a societal
level and these
this societal programming of men is
causing us all to make the same mistakes
you know and so guys are just out here
doing stuff that like is completely
unnecessary
you know you don't have to fail in
certain areas of your relationships and
that's why it's easy for me and i you
know i i do brag about it
you know i have a very high success rate
in helping people get their
relationships on track
just because i people aren't doing
something different and even if you were
i'd still figure it out because
it's a variation of something you know
that you shouldn't be doing
or she shouldn't be doing and so it's
just a matter of just you know listening
to the person
listening to the lopsided one-sided
story of the guy because
even guys as rational and reasonable as
we are we tell lopsided stories that are
in our favor
and in figuring out and saying like okay
this can't be possible
that you know you're doing everything
perfectly right like this like this
because
you're a human being you're screwing up
somewhere and so figuring out the story
and the stories are always overlapping
and so they're always the same pattern
in terms of human behaviors because
human behavior is like spoke on a wheel
of a bicycle you know what leads to the
rim
you know so yeah so yeah so
for me that was very important you know
to help people get married and stay
married
yeah it's very important i mean you
don't want you don't you don't want to
get married a whole bunch of times
yeah you know you don't you don't want
to do it you know um all right so
i'm gonna ask you one last question and
then mommy if you could think of
anything
you can ask here one last question and
before we get
get right into that and proceed with
that people want to get more you they
want to get
guides they want to get your programs
they want to reach out to you for maybe
consultations
where can they find you out man on my
website audibleamerican.com
you know um you can find me at
american.com or you can find me on
twitter at apple american
basically anywhere you go online and you
look up american i'm there
you know put in the description box
you know i am uh i'm on tick tock i'm
here i'm there but the easiest way to
contact me
is from twitter at [ __ ] american or my
website at all american.com go ahead and
you know jump on
you know the live chat or or email
you know you can contact me there but
twitter i'm almost always there i'm on
twitter a lot
alternatively um people you can go to
like one of those feminist blogs where
you found like the top 20 people on
their list
that they hate they can't stand you'll
find them there
it too i'm pretty sure yeah
anyway craig uh i'm gonna go right into
my question
long distance man might sound like a
statement but
i don't need to ask anything what are
your thoughts on it do you believe in it
as a muslim man
where do you draw the line between long
distance and no long distance what do
you do if you find someone that
they meet your criteria but it's like
what am i going to do they're like in
the middle of nowhere they're far from
me
should i proceed should i not do i talk
to them online um or if you're currently
in a relationship and for some reason it
has to go a long distance what are your
thoughts on anything like that
i'm trying not to go long distance it
can work but it's it's difficult it's
very difficult i'd say don't do it you
know in my humble opinion i'm currently
my third wife is long distance
i haven't seen her in a year i
physically have not seen her in a year
it's very difficult for her it's very
difficult for me
um it hasn't reduced the affection or
anything but
you know it's just it's far from ideal
you know
i have no intention of divorcing or
anything because of it you know but it's
just
it it it does complicate the
relationship you know
it's and it's not easy don't do it
because
you're putting yourself in a hardship
you're putting her in hardship
and um it puts a lot of strain on
everybody because
everybody has desires emotional physical
you know
company and companionship these are
things you can't provide
at a distance you know you can chat and
all that stuff have fun
laugh online but at the end of the day
we're human beings we're social beings
and that social
that social aspect is also physical you
know so
and i mean this goes for anything this
is this includes brotherhood
i mean we're talking specifically
marriage but we can bring this in also
i mean if you want to really get along
with a guy
be close to that guy train with him
fight with them and when i say fight you
know go out boxing wrestling whatever
else
you'll find out how close you become
because we are
those social beings so how much more
important is it
you know for your family in terms of
your wives you know or your wife
just i wouldn't advise it it can't work
yes it can
but it takes copious amounts of money
copious amounts of free
time to travel you know and go see them
that money to spend
traveling and going to see them you know
and it's just
any other time differences which we're
not even going to touch upon sometimes
if you ever get uh you know it would be
amazing if you uh you can chop it up
with gabriel or romani
uh brother yours if any of you don't
know he's profound and we can get him on
the
on the chat too or on live and i think
he made a video about him one day that i
was watching
and he said that all those fathers that
are they start a family here and then
they go back to like south
they go back to work and they just
completely neglect them and they don't
realize what they're doing
but it's crazy man yeah it's difficult
man i
wouldn't advise it i wouldn't advise it
is it permissible can you do it
absolutely
is it advisable from my positioning
standpoint no
no i wouldn't i wouldn't advise anybody
to do it
all right that's that's really i can't
say much more than that really
mm-hmm yeah
and it doesn't help i mean who could
have predicted to top it off
global pandemics and all this stuff
there's so many like unpredictable
factors
also you know i mean look at this we're
in the middle of a global pathetic where
people can't
pandemic um
[Music]
you know people can't travel this that
the other you know
without crazy vaccines and all this
stuff for you know it's just
it's just bad man you know there's that
unpredictable factor also
you know what i mean yeah yeah that's
true with all things in life
unfortunately uh recently um
showed me a video with elliot hulse's
father and he just he basically said
um just do nothing in situations where
you can't control it do nothing because
there's nothing to do
and you know worrying about it isn't
really going to help so just work on
yourself and work on what you can work
on and the rest will kind of fall into
place
i mean it's amazing because you find
this yeah you find this in islamic
traditions as well right
uh the prophet he advised a man tie your
camel
and trust in allah right do what you can
and trust in allah the reason you have
to trust in allah is because
one without allah nothing happens and
two allah is the only one who controls
everything
and as humans being dependent being weak
in certain areas
we can't control everything obviously
um so firstly i want to say to everybody
who's watching you know there are a lot
of gems alhamdulillah in this a very
specific moments uh when abu was
speaking
may allah bless you um things like
where to start where to begin things to
work on and all of that starts
internally
even allah says in the quran i will not
change the position of a person or
people until they change within
themselves
so if you want things outside externally
to become better you must internally
become better as well
so go back and watch you know very
specific points of the five things you
said
you know uh are important to work on and
and internally becoming competent and so
on and so forth
uh it starts with you now moving into
that um
it seems to be the case that all
divorces
the beginning of a divorce is just
choosing the wrong person
so how would you go sorry go on go on no
no please please
continue the question okay so basically
it seems to be that all divorces are you
know bad
is bad choices at the beginning so how
would a person an individual
um or i guess most of our audiences men
how would a man go about finding a woman
i know you have a vetting guide on it do
you want to quickly
plug that in and talk about it yeah like
all about just screening in general red
flags anything you want to add in oh
man i wrote a whole guide about that
that's a tough one there's a lot of red
flags um let me start off like this i
generally say
it's always your fault as a man remember
what i was saying about the burden of
performance the burden of performance is
yours as a man
so first off make sure that in a
marriage you're
you're not you're not the person that
needs vetting
do you know what i mean make sure you're
not the you're not like the piece of
trash person
you know work on yourself nobody expects
you to be perfect you're not going to be
perfect you're human
you know we're not we're not perfect
but at the same time make sure you're
not like you know you're not a hot mess
you know make sure you're not you're not
a messy person
you know um because if you're a messy
person internally um
there's no way you can have like a solid
relationship with somebody that isn't
messy also that's going to
if your finances are messy your
relationship's going to be messy if your
emotions are messy
the emotional condition of your
relationship's gonna be messy make sure
first and foremost start off with
yourself and make sure you're in the
position
in all ways to be uh
uh in a relationship once you have that
because you can control that you can't
control what the other person is or
isn't
but what you can control is you can
internalize who and what you are
so make sure you're the best possible
version of yourself and i mentioned that
before
and that's something that i mention a
lot you know um when i talk about guys
and relationships whatever else even
with women make sure you're the best
possible version of yourself
and this isn't like although you can use
it this way it's not the intention
is that you become the least blame
worthy person in the relationship that's
not to say once you separate with
someone if it happens may i protect you
from that
that you go around well i was perfect
and that person was trash no
it's just you can leave the relationship
with a clear and clean heart that you
did the best that you could
to make sure that that relationship
stayed intact this is universal
this applies to men and this applies to
women you know because
you don't want to leave a relationship
knowing
you screwed up and then spending like
the next two three years
uh uh what's the word i'm looking for
rationalizing why the other person was
so bad and what they did no
but really it was just you you know it's
not gonna feel good guys it's not gonna
feel good i've
messed up relationships and then i mean
to this day those relationships are 10
10 years ago and i'm still thinking
about man yeah i really dropped the ball
there
you don't like that you don't want to
live like that you don't want to have
that inside that's
you know so make sure that's the first
point
um next
when it comes down to vetting wow
i don't even know where to start guys i
mean that's a lot i mean there's a lot
of red flags to look out for
and the only reason why i say there's a
lot of red flags to look out for is
because social media has corrupted a lot
of our society as we know it
you know we have a lot of like strange
ideas concepts
people's weird lusts and desires going
out there infecting other people making
them sick
it's like you know we had separation it
was like you know when we didn't have
social media it kind of acted like a
societal
fire door now that fire door is gone and
people's weird proclivities are out
there and other people are like picking
these things up like some sort of
illness
you know so the the number of red flags
that you can find in people nowadays is
quite
extreme and so you have to be very
careful in looking
at making sure these people reflect
and share with you are considerable
degrees of virtues
values ethics and morals of course the
start of this is islam
you know but then there's within
cultural differences and ideas
there are some things that are flexible
you know also
so the foundation is islam do they
reflect your islam and after that
you know in terms of other areas in your
life that they reflect
but for but for men one of the most
important things i would look out for in
a woman is like excessive
social media usage one of the first
things you want to do
is uh just you know look at her social
media and just look at what type of
person she is
you know i mean here's one thing that
you're gonna
you shouldn't know is that women
generally don't separate
their actual lives from their social
media lives one is a reflection of the
other
and to them there's no difference
between the two
one thing that people do especially
women they make a mistake of is thinking
that abu american
and i don't play a two-faced person if
you meet me in person i'm generally like
this but
online i'm just like i'm really edgy
whatever else they think i'm a horrible
misogynist
you know woman hater but then i got
these women who love me so much online
and they're my biggest fans online
they should in their mind put together
that they're missing like housing
misogynist but these women love him
you know so either these are like messed
up women which obviously
can't be the case because there's you
know multiple women in my lives
or my understanding of who this
individual is wrong
they don't separate social media from
real life
and social media isn't real life so look
at how she uses social media guys this
is a
huge point that you cannot overlook
i can't underestimate or understate
how important this is look at her social
media
you know and i mean even that is a
science on its own is she being like you
know
is she posting a bunch of stuff then
deleting it then reposting stuff
why you know all these types of stuff is
she trying to hide the double lives they
said the other
does she have secret snapchats that her
parents and whatever else don't know
about
all these things you need to look at
know and find out
and um yeah you need to keep an eye on
as a guy
you know women
i mean shoot you know i spend so much
time looking at women you know
uh that i don't really know how to tell
a woman what to look out for a guy
you know in a guy because my entire
thing has been like guys be the best
version of yourself that you can be
so for me you know it's like i'm out
here telling guys to be the best that
they can so i'm not really sure what to
tell women to look for because
you know i if a guy is a mess in general
i just you know you're just like you
know something wrong with that guy and i
just sort of back away from him you know
what i mean
so if you if you're starting to spot
like red flags in that way too you do
the same thing but i just
i can't put my finger on it because i
haven't really been i don't coach women
so
i'm really looking at guys like that if
a guy's not being his best self i just
tell him hey look man you're screwing up
here
you need to take action you know um so
i would say like you know what actually
i do have an answer sorry
turn to the men folk your family you
know you got to trust them
they want the best for you maybe they
won't find the guy that you find most
attractive but they do want the best for
you they're going to try
their best to find the most attractive
man be honest with your family as a
woman
tell them i like a guy who's like this i
like i like a guy who's like that you
know and don't be shy and don't be
scared because what you don't want to do
is you don't want to end up in a
situation where you're married to a guy
that you're not attracted to
you know and then it leads to problems
in your relationship where because women
we know you all have wandering eyes too
you know and it can lead to problems for
you also
you know we we understand that you're
not creatures that are without desires
and any guys watching this don't believe
that stop doing this whole
you know making the apotheosis of women
they're not angels
they desire you know physical
interaction just as much
as you do and they want to do it with
someone they're attracted with
attracted to just like you do so you
know
so women be be honest with your family
there's a sister she's asian i believe
she's pakistani
i can't i'm not sure it doesn't matter
but she's she's southeast asian she
wants to marry a black guy
you know for her family that's a huge
leap
but she was honest with her family she
said that's what i want that's what i'm
attracted to i'm attracted to
it was a specific black guy it wasn't
just black guys in general but if that's
your flavor
then do it then maybe hopefully
inshallah your family helps you
find the best guy that they can and
men we're good at spotting other dudes
bs we just got a radar for it we know
when a guy is on some bs am i wrong guys
we know when that guy ain't about jack
jack
jack doo doo there's no results yeah
yeah so we see it we're like man that
dude ain't no good man what you talking
about
you know but she might be attracted to
that but what you can do is you can help
her find a guy that she will find
attractive you know and who's going to
be responsible and serious about her and
towards her and marry her
so women be you know trust you trust
your men folk that they want the best
for you
but be adamant in making sure that your
men folks understand that you know what
you want and what you find attractive
you know because it's not it doesn't
serve you you know to just be like
okay i'll marry this guy and then like
two years later you're divorced
you know and then you got a kid and
you're looking to get married again you
know
and then just things start going all
over the place and things are going i
mean i've seen this a lot especially in
london you know then things go left
field after that then it's just all over
the place and
it's a hot mess why did you go through
all that in the first place you know
it's not necessary so you know so for
the women turn to your men folk be
honest with them
be start with your mom you know if you
think she's gonna be more um
open and accepting and then let her do
the heavy lifting you know in terms of
speaking to your father or whatever else
and helping you get the man that you
really want to get
i'd say that's that's yeah the basic
advice i could give
i have a comprehensive guide um for men
you know it's my vetting guide if guys
are like 15 and 16 like you said
watching this is going to be too
expensive for them to be
honest it's you know it's like it's 97
euros or something like this
um but it's my life's work you know in
terms of like oh man
i'm not i'm not i'm just boosting it up
for you but i read your description
and it's like at the end of the day look
at the thousands they might be saving
on things that might come up man that 97
is is pale
in comparison to like divorce fees child
child uh
what is it you know child support
alimony
don't get me started just a heartbreak
man just heartbreak it's not something
you really want to experience like in a
bad way you know
i mean and that's not to say it's going
to protect you from getting your heart
broken but it can it can
make it easier on you in terms of like
you know you you know you did your best
you know if you have to walk away from a
relationship as a man at least you want
to know does it you know i did i did my
due diligence i checked her out i did
the best i could
i was the best man i could possibly be
in a relationship and somehow
you know for whatever reason that wasn't
good enough well maybe it's not me maybe
it's just her
you know just to quickly add in here i
would say for anyone who's 15 16 or
even no matter how old they are a person
who can't afford
that you know because it's it's not that
much what what did you say 70 euros
97 yeah 97 euros okay honestly
for something that this important i
wouldn't say it's not much and if they
can't afford it the first step
is not buying the book the first step is
getting on their game because if you
can't afford a book
to you know educate yourself on such an
important matter
then you're the issue not not not
affording the book you have to be able
to afford the book and get on your feet
first
how are you going to support a wife like
you can have a woman
yeah to get a wife but you can't afford
the book that's going to give the
information how are you going to afford
a wife
and guys i did you know i'm not this
this is in the sales pitch
i did this for you for free for like
seven years
american and uh you know
i just recently started charging for my
consultations like last year
and this guy you know this is a classic
example of what he's talking about this
is a very good point romney made
you know this guy he hits me up his wife
is you know she's off the rails she's
running around with other guys we're not
saying she's
making fornication or anything but she's
definitely out you know like chatting up
other guys whatever else and he's
he really wants to keep the woman and i
tell him okay you're gonna have to do a
one-to-one consultation we need to
really figure this out we need to get
like you know a solid plan
to see if this is salvageable you know
or whether you need to let go you know
because it was a really bad situation
so i sent him a link to pay for the
one-to-one consultation
then he comes back he says it's too
expensive you know but i had spoken to
him for like you know a few days
and i know for a fact this guy spent
like 80 000 british pounds
on his wedding so you have to look at
what he values
he spent 80 000 british pounds on his
marriage but he's not willing to spend
like a few hundred pounds on a
one-to-one consultation to save the
marriage
so the ones that do and i have i have a
100 hit rate
i've never failed to help someone get
their position
right with their woman i haven't failed
and i haven't done just one or two
consultations i've done a lot
he goes to a counselor and he pays them
thousands
[Music]
if you look at the statistics on
counseling on marriage counseling go and
research the statistics on marriage
counseling nine times out of ten they
fail
they have a higher fail rate than
success rate marriage counseling
but i'm sitting here with like a near
100 hit rate i think there's one
relationship i couldn't save
and i mean when i said i couldn't save i
couldn't get it in the way that the guy
wanted it he got married he was marrying
a girl and he wanted her in a particular
way you know in his frame and there was
a lot of pl a lot of family influence
whatever else and so there was just no
real way to get him what he wanted
but he still got married so it's like i
considered that a fail in my particular
part because she didn't marry him in the
way that he wanted her to marry him
you know i considered that a fan you
know on my part you know he paid me and
i took it seriously you know i tried to
help him to get the
you know the marriage the way he wanted
so guys
you know you do have to put in the work
you know and you have to understand what
is valuable to you
the difference between cost and value
you know and what something
you know is worth you know cost value
and worth and i teach my kids this all
the time
they're not the same cost value and
worth you know what something's going to
cost you
what is it worth and how much do you
value it and this right here is the most
important point you know
do you value what you're about the part
you know most people overvalue something
they're willing to pay too much for it
or they don't value it enough and
therefore they're not willing enough to
pay for it you know i mean if you don't
find value in what i do
you know you can watch some of my videos
and whatnot you know read some of the
you know
the testimonials you know fellas take
notes like this
you guys are out here like scared to
marry a guy because of what your parents
are going to say you're scared to do
this scared to do that it's gonna like
tell your parents how it is abu american
helped because i'm from bangladesh right
so there's a bengali girl
this man helped a bengali girl marry a
black guy
and convince her parents and not only
that what was the cherry on top bro
um oh with the with the uh the sister
that that's gonna marry the black guy
what was the cherry on top oh as his
third wife
as his third wife and i think you guided
them through it and just worked out
yeah this is unheard of in the bengali
community this was
completely unheard of bro
[Laughter]
but all it takes but i know enough about
him that
like that's like like what like i was
surprised it worked i was surprised at
work but i was like look this is what
you got to do if you couldn't get this
to work
i'm just like i was like culture's going
to take over and there's no way it's
going to happen
you know but
all right guys with that being said uh
go down below in the comments
if you liked it let us know how you
think so when abu looks at it he
definitely knows to get his mind right
and get back on this for part two
and inshallah we're gonna do live uh
sometime in the near future rami why
don't you uh close it off for us today
you're like so i'm is craig it's been a
pleasure having you until next time
yeah it's the same pleasure being here